nous sommes maintenant à cinq semaines
des élections municipales gros plan ce
soir sur la ville d'angers une mairie
socialiste depuis trente ans que je rêve
de reconquérir la droite particularité
on retrouve des centristes sur les deux
principales listes et reportage de
caroline hunter et j'en ai en arrière
c'est un homme pressé christophe béchu
33 ans jeunes pousses de l'ump il est
président du conseil général depuis
quatre ans il rêve à présent de
s'installer à la mairie d'angers
avocat de formation son parcours n'est
pas sans rappeler celui du président de
la république ses détracteurs l'ont
d'ailleurs surnommé l' aider sarkozy
je trouve un peu navrant un peu
déplorable que l'argument politique
principal qui sera mis en avant par mon
adversaire
ce soit celui de bébé sarkozy c'est à la
fois une critique en terme d'âge une
volonté vraiment de politiser les choses
j'utilise pas l'expression de pépé
jospin pour parler de ceux qui sont en
face de moi est celui qui est face à lui
le voici
jean claude antonini 67 printemps maire
ps sortant à la tête de la ville depuis
dix ans certains lui reprochent de
tenter le mandat de trop j veu diret
l'âge il ya des petits billard de 25 ans
30 ans et il ya des gens extrêmement
jeunes qui ont 80 ans à angers la guerre
des générations est dans la place mais
c'est avant tout sur le terrain de
l'ouverture que l'élection va se jouer
ainsi sur la liste ump de christophe
béchu
on retrouve l'ancienne première adjointe
centriste de l'équipe sortante
un socialiste et l'investiture
officielle du modem une petite devise
avec mes amis du globe qui de dire b
rouen rêver nous le ferons à angers ça
j'y crois beaucoup c'est à dire cette
capacité de déchirer les étiquettes
politiques et de rassembler à angers des
compétences pour notre ville est en fait
de faire l'échelle locale ce qu'ils
proposaient l'échelle nationale mais
brouillon un peu plus les cartes ont
centristes déçus de l'absence d'une
liste modem ont choisi de rejoindre le
camp de la gauche avec avec 24%
présidentielle a presque
nous avions fait je lisais les autres
aux législatives il ya un terroir qui et
c'est une terre des centristes ranger et
l'anjou en général donc il y avait
essayé une ville en france où il y
aurait dû avoir une liste autonome
c'était bien arrangé à l'automne dernier
un sondage donnait le maire sortant
vainqueur à 58 % dès le premier tour
mais c'était bien avant le jeu des
multiples ranimant